welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link at the round table of dim
lighting this week we have Dave d'andrea
the voice of electronic battleship the
board game yes and the reason that Dave
and the voice you have sunk your
battleship electronic battleship is
significant to us is because on an
episode of good mythical morning back in
August of last year we played electronic
battleship and we were so impressed and
I would say moved by the voice yeah that
was leading us through the game he added
a whole other dimension to a game that
otherwise I wasn't motivated to playing
right and we were so moved by this voice
that we started talking about how we had
to get in contact with this guy figuring
that if we set it on the show somebody
he'd get in touch with him yeah we just
started talking directly to Dave even
though we didn't know his name was Dave
right and we didn't know that he didn't
live in Ohio even though for some reason
we presumed all that he did he sounded
like and then yes many it took many
months as much because he might say oh
no initial response thanks to the
mythical beast talking to him over
twitter with a tweet that he sent our
way it's worked out and this is it this
is the culmination yeah that's what this
air biscuit is going to be a
conversation with it it's the
culmination of all you know all of that
just you never know what happens if you
start playing battleship right well this
is what happens yeah yeah you end up
talking to the voice of it so that's
coming up in a second but before before
that we're coming off of a trip a little
trip we took to Amsterdam
yeah so let's let's share some some
highlights well I would say just first
of all I learned something because I was
actually on on a tour of a castle a
castle that you also went to but you
didn't take the tour well we went at
different times and we by the the last
day of our trip which we brought our
families with us we each went off on a
little wife excursion or an excursion
without that's what you call it
no that's something else but Chrissy and
I went on an excursion but we went to
count castles yeah and we went to the
same castle at different times on the
same day but while I was on the tour
the guy said does anyone know that he
asked the all the Americans he says do
any of you know the difference between
Holland and the Netherlands and I was
like no I waited for another American to
say something and you didn't audibly say
no no I saw state nope but it turns out
that the difference is well you know the
difference you were just there the
difference is that Holland
is is the name of two provinces there's
like an like northern Holland and then
like a southern Holland or something I
can't remember what they are but they're
not all of the Netherlands which is the
whole shebang yeah of many provinces
including the two holland ones yeah so
Holland is a region of the Netherlands
and it's like the Northwest area where
Amsterdam and Amsterdam is a city and
canals are the water things that are cut
all throughout 1/3 of the Netherlands
and all throughout and I saw their
column Kennels know the canals right
well that's something else I should have
paid attention on the tour I thought it
was called kennels the whole time and
you know what you can take a taxi on a
kaenel we took a bus taxi to vidcon
Europe to do our thing
yeah well just make a smoothie of
Amsterdam foods and then almost vomit on
stage it was the best er damn Sweeney
I've ever had it was actually pretty
nice but the when we met a lot of
mythical yeah shout out special ear
biscuits shout out to all the mythical
beasts many of you showed up for the
meet-and-greet and for the qat
there were lots of hugs yeah
we had people line up asking us
questions which we answered and then I
saw that Shep was in the back of the
live my son and so for the whole like 50
minutes of the hour the QA he can't he
was waiting in the back of the line
patiently to get up to the microphone to
ask us a question
you don't let the boy asking questions
normally no I tell him no speaking to
daddy but then by the by the ends go
through your mother by the end all
answers come from daddy he had given up
the he'd given up hope he wasn't in line
anymore but got bored you know what
question he was gonna ask yeah he told
me he was like dad I was going to ask
why are you my dad and I was like well
you should have done that that would
have been awesome it would have been
very funny and I talked to Jesse he
might have been awkward and she said
answer he got bored he said he got bored
I mean I got bored he stood there sweet
he stood there for an hour it was an
hour long queue and he's eight year old
but anyway it's just his dad talking on
a stage I'm great meeting all you guys
that came out but we had an incredible
time and it was the high it was the
highlight to Castle because for me the
highlight was the windmill the word I'm
freaking windmills the highlight for me
was the same day but it was right after
than with Mel and it was the cheese the
cheese place and you realized that
wasn't a few factories this is a cheese
shop and they made it look like a
factory downstairs so they keep giving
it like I don't care it was just a ploy
to sell cheese they don't actually make
the cheese they I got to taste 27
different types of cheeses
I found myself liking cheese they're a
lot more than I ever have anywhere else
I enjoyed that whole day though
oh yeah windmills were great the store
we went to the chocolate place and we
got to make the hot chocolate but see
here's the difference that was just a
gift shop - right but here's the
difference between they don't actually
make Chuck it's not a chocolate fact we
had eleven people in our in our in our
posse yeah yeah yeah our posse consisted
of us our wives our kids and some
babysitter's yeah and I know what you're
gonna say it's fine we go into this
chocolate shop there they called it the
chocolate lab which got me really
excited and listen a gift shop yeah yeah
but in the middle of the thing they had
Dutch chocolate and you were supposed to
take a spoonful of the dutch chocolate
powder spoonful of sugar and mix it with
some milk and they would give you hot
milk and I requested hot soy milk
because I don't like I don't drink you
know I'm lactose intolerant
what okay all 11 of us are in there and
10 of us decide to get this is 2 euros
apiece and then you didn't get it you're
like yeah and then you like taste it a
little bit of Christmas he didn't let me
taste it action we're on vacation man I
just don't understand you had the
opportunity to taste to experience this
thing in your pants you just I had the
opportunity to make myself a cup of hot
chocolate and then taste it I mean it
was the best bit there gone no you
haven't you've had Smith's Swiss Miss
it's different than what just chocolate
it no it was incredible it was on
another level it was character you made
up your mind for it to be that and I'm
not gonna take that away from you no and
it was better it was the best hot
chocolate I've ever had it was special
and I'm not gonna take it away for
whether or not it was better in my mind
because I was on vacation I just don't
know what I just don't understand that
I'm not gonna try that I wasn't thirsty
I think that's your problem
you think hot chocolate is when you're
thirsty hot choc is that because the
thirst for it's for chocolate is feeling
good it's rich and it may it weighs me
down the cup was this big it was like a
swish Cup from from childhood man I
didn't want to pay two dollars for
something that I had to make but listen
but I will say I didn't say anything
mean if I would pay two dollars for
euros for it I didn't say anything at
the time we're on vacation I didn't want
to silent a judge I silently judged you
and then we went to the cheese place and
I was like if he's gonna walk through
here without eating this cheese I'm
gonna say something to him but then I
look over there and you're eating all
the cheese and I was like it's like
watching a rat in a maze like which way
is he gonna go and again I I don't think
I've talked about this because we've
talked a lot about how multiple times
don't good mythical morning good
mythical more and maybe even ear
biscuits about this dynamic between
someone who wants to try a lot of new
things and someone who doesn't want to
try a lot of new things and how you
shouldn't get annoyed at someone that
doesn't want to try new things because
how does it affect you and I've always
thought that's a compelling reason and I
get it but I've actually come up with a
theory of why it isn't
annoying and is justified to defend
yourself okay and it is because you know
when you meet somebody and you find out
that you've got something in common with
them you've got a common experience
you've got a common worldview you agree
about something maybe it's political
whatever it might be and when you find
out that you agree about something you
feel this bond with them I think that
one of the reasons that you want to
experience something with someone at you
and you want them to try it and you want
them to have an opinion in and you kind
of want them to have the same opinion
like if you taste this pizza and you're
like this place this pizza place has the
best pizza in the world and you take
somebody to eat that pizza and then they
eat it and they're like that's okay is
it the fact that they made you look
stupid and that's why you didn't do you
don't like that well that's probably a
little bit of it but also if they say
that they know this is the greatest
piece in the world this shared
experience there's some sort of adaptive
advantage that's built into our DNA that
there's a sense of like there's like an
endorphin rush when you agree with
somebody on something and you can
experience something to have the same
perspective on it and I think that
that's what I'm searching for so when I
went when I had nine other people to
have that with with your hot chocolate
nobody but I I'm sorry but it would have
been it would have been that much better
if everybody was enjoying it all of the
same time so it was so thick that's what
made it so good but what I was saying I
just didn't have apps when we went into
the cheese shop and you enjoyed the
cheese I got an endorphin rush from you
eating cheese you see how this works
uh I just enjoyed the cheese but can you
isn't like corn burger could infer great
if you love something a whole lot yeah I
get that there's like I understand
they're not coming that I'm not
interested but I also didn't do that no
you didn't do that but I would
understand if somebody like Debbie downs
the thing that you're loving like this
is the best pizza I've ever had wouldn't
I mean I've had better pieces that way I
don't want to hear that it's like that's
not yet
I'm just saying I'm not I'm not
defending myself I'm saying I'm like I
wouldn't have felt good it finally hit
me why it's important to me it finally
clicked in my mind but I know why I have
a problem when somebody doesn't want to
try something or enjoy something right I
quit I can't always be that for you well
but whenever you can I'd appreciate it I
I do understand that I'm keenly aware of
what you want from I did like the
windmill I gotta say not be the center
of your happiness the windmill was was a
great experience I know you enjoyed that
too I know I've been that for years but
it's you know I'm gonna have to step out
of the throne and the candles were great
the candles were great we took a boat
ride just the two of us in one captain
but for me I felt like we had it with
the windmills
I mean we're walking around there's a
millstone that is twice the the diameter
of this round table and then the guy the
Dutch man in his clogs is explaining how
he literally takes linseed puts it on
the mill stone grinds it into linseed
oil which is then used to make paint
paint paint and then he says that the
mill stone when they originally put it
in as a replacement by the way yeah it
was twice do you remember what year it
was put in no what year just guess I
wanna just guessing it's 2017 now 1960
he was 1865 that millstone that
millstone first of all the whole freak
well it was twice as big but originally
but the whole thing was I don't think it
took that long in the 1600s the thing we
were in was built in the 1600s and then
200 years into the life of this mill
they replace the millstone and it's
always been you know what I didn't use
it they don't use it as much I know but
I was like seventy years or whatever the
math is on that but looking at it and
also how did you get it there and he was
like police it like I was asking a
stupid question how on earth did you get
this millstone up here I guess I
insulted him I mean you're wearing
wooden shoes how did you get
in police and you know while we were in
that in that inside the there was the
windmill ours nothing there was there
was nothing by the way to prevent you
from sticking a head or a hand or a foot
or a whole body I love it over there in
America's motion in America there's got
to be signs on everything you got it oh
you got to tell people to watch their
step but this seems a little bit weird
every you gotta put ropes around cord
into off in Europe that you you if a kid
mmm falls crooked one way and gets their
head under a millstone that's it that's
that's the kids problem pop goes the
skull you know what why are you got to
protect everybody from everything over
here
I didn't even let people live their
freakin life blood stains anyway if the
kid wants to jump under a millstone let
him do it learn his lesson did you see
any blood stains no I didn't mean I
think it just mixes right in with a
thing right when I walked in I was like
the whole windmill was turning the
millstone was turning I was like man if
I tripped and fell a pop my skull under
this thing and it would be your fault
and then I the way life works and
there's no get weeded out of the gene
pool there's a wooden staircase that's
like super narrow and like rickety and
I'm like well I can't go up there and
then I'm looking for the sign I'm like
there's no sign there's no cordon
I can't go up there Gordon and then if
you know you how you coordinate stunt
mom yeah yeah I just usually don't use
it there that way James Corden yeah
that's what he's got a barrier around
bottoms and then after the guy runs us
through the linseed thing he's like go
around look at the mill that's not in
any way what he said a little Irish so I
went up the stairs I went up the stairs
yeah you did and and I and my kids went
up there and you know what there was one
place that there was a cordon and it had
a skull on it and in it and it kept you
from walking under where the the actual
windmill blades came down because that
they protected you from that because
they do because everyone well they're
not idiots
you know yeah I'd be bad fright PR but
while you were up there I was downstairs
listening to Edgar our tour guide there
was a piano and
was singing isn't she lovely Stevie
Wonder yeah he was singing that in the I
heard him it was echoing through the
middle and it's a it's a memory I'll
never forget that was a good moment I
was my friend that was one of my
highlights when he started singing
Stevie Wonder in a Dutch windmill and
you know what I enjoyed it too at the
same time and that gave me wonder it
gave you a thrill yeah I'm a windmill
thrill we'll have to go back sometime
there's no thrill greater than a
windmill thrill just the two of us no
wife excursions or any oh well we should
probably bring them too I'm always up
for a wife excursion Oh what else I'm up
for t-shirts yes we are very happy to
announce a number of new exclusive
t-shirts bike in limited run here's one
t-shirts what do you got over there
laying just yourself be if weird is you
that's something we said on good
mythical morning but only for a limited
time can you put it on your body in this
shirt form
this is boiled for safety you know who
got the boil for safety mug because boil
for safety is something that we say on
good mythical morning and now we've got
a boil for safety t-shirt again just for
a limited time now one cool thing about
all these new wax paper dogs shirt
that's the band that we were in in high
school it's like got a cool faded retro
that's the thing that's in style now
apparently we've been told that that
kind of shirts in style that's why we're
offering it to you for an exclusive
period of time and readily accomplished
or all of these these t-shirts look at
that now have are made by mythical
insignia is that it really is it an
asset and insignia or is it just a logo
it's a sauna in Cygnus and insignia man
it's it's got a cordon around it made by
mythical you know it's made by mythical
you know it's soft you know it's good it
is can wear it in the kennels you can
wear it 50 t-shirts are worn ring spun
cotton
get them while they're here to get
because they won't be here for long cuz
they'll be gone when they're gone
rattling comm slash store now let's get
on with this biscuit with Dave D'Andrea
oh man that voice was great the
conversation was great had some big
laughs and some windmill thrills no
windmills involved though didn't even
need him nope
my son ain't guacamole healthy he's a
hungry boy he's a growing boy
got a heat tackle akamalik off your feet
yeah oh he was I couldn't see who was
eatin awful where you thought the feed
cheese tasted pretty good
yeah bringing him up right was there
cheese on the feet oh yeah there was
cheese everywhere man mmm
here love up on that Michael this is how
we do it all right
like see Stella voiceover got how to use
a microphone nah cuz I couldn't even
hear you okay all right I can hear you
so better it's good this is the
wonderful thing about the Internet is
that we can have a conversation on good
mythical morning about how we got to get
in touch with this battleship voice guy
and then months later
I mean months right because that was
like August it wasn't just yeah it
starts to happen we're all here we're
all hanging out and because we're having
our night on the town that we talk about
welcome Dave this is it man thank you
I'm so honored literally well we're
honored too because see I mean I think I
haven't watched it back you've watched
it back just kind of refresh it up since
it's been like the fresh fresh yourself
you got a refreshing ship before you
refresh your ship but did you refresh I
would fresh yeah I did not reverse my
selfish but we had yesterday voice
Edition dog food commercial comedy I
need to refresh myself with some dog
food if they bring back like the Popeye
cartoons those could be like some side
guys I'm not really refreshing I don't
get that spinach guy I don't understand
he's got a lot of muscles on his forearm
it's weird to say you have to what about
infection from the tattoos bicep day
yeah but we had you tell me cuz you just
refresh yourself and watched it back
well they may say this ironically I'm
having a voice issue today I don't know
if it's like intimidation that you were
gonna be here or the cold that I just
I'm coming down with but my voice is
cracking I've got some UI tea I've got
water to back up the tea
got to crackly voice but I might just be
a little intimidated you say you're
getting a cold yeah that's like the
worst case scenario for vo guy you don't
like that worst case what's your if I
don't you try to stay healthy my kids
are home-schooled so they're not
bringing anything home with them that's
all right just keep it right there
that's wrong keep them in there but you
just yeah you try to stay healthy and
stay hydrated
look at me look at how healthy look help
you god I mean this is dim light except
everybody looks pretty good in this
lighting but I'm most thankful for the
pallor you got a good pallor more
voiceover guy yeah but you don't have
but you don't have to look good as we
see this side the whole thing you look
good for a vo guy great face for radio
what am I trying to say is well you're
somebody great joke for you to make yeah
but we can't make it let you have it
we've had faith and what is what I've
been trying to say yeah we had faith in
the internet that the internet would
bring us together I mean we didn't like
okay we had the battleship and we were
playing it well I would just say that we
didn't we didn't read when we started
talking about the battleship guy we were
just like all right we want to meet you
we started talking to you right through
good mythical more but we didn't look on
the box or Google anything I think Eddie
may have googled stuff and I'm like I
don't care about that I don't nothing
came up nothing came up with your name
or anything it was like but we have
faith it may take weeks it may take
months it may take years it may take a
lifetime but we will meet this is it our
faith in the Internet holds strong
because of this moment this is a tent
peg this is going in the ground so when
I start slipping in my faith in in the
Internet this is wavering mm-hmm and I'm
sliding I'm gonna grab this tent peg I'm
gonna say you know what I remember when
I would put this one in the ground this
is when we knew we were gonna meet Dave
and then we did but you're also assuming
that this
that Dave is the guy that does the game
I mean he said he's the guy that does
the game actually lots of guys in your
comments that they were the guy that did
the game right but there's only one way
to prove that you're the guy that did
the game you're the guy that's here and
we've got the game right the battle how
many things are you saying shut up see
they have me do like just like you know
I mean I already know it's a man sick
tone is the same so the battle has just
begun the battle has begun that's him
the game and then what else did you say
press I don't know they they this was I
did this like five years ago happy it
was if this was so funny because I did
it and I didn't even know exactly what I
was
voiceover doing the voice-over for I
thought maybe was like a little handheld
thing or an app I didn't know when you
say you sunk my battleship that can only
be one I knew his battleship but I think
this is right around the time the film
came out and then a couple years later
Rihanna was in that I'm thinking oh my
son did you meet Rihanna well we were
hoping you'd bring her no sorry we left
his face in every day battleship I'm
sorry can you say Rihanna sunk your
battleship in the voice yeah Rihanna
sunk your battleship okay you're
definitely the guy we don't even have to
play the game how long ago it was about
five years ago and then a couple years
ago a friend of mine said hey are you
the voice we just bought this this
battleship game are you the voice on
there I'm like no I didn't do any
battleship game totally forgot about it
and he was in CID no I'm pretty sure
it's here I said well plainly some of
the audio and so we did him oh yeah I
totally did that
I did forget and then a month ago or
whatever it was somebody sent a message
to my wife and that we're home binge
watching Little House on the Prairie or
whatever we were doing no we're on this
band right now Little House on the
Prairie
you know there's a lot we've
homeschooled our kids as well we only
let them watch little house pray we cook
window we understand bridge my kids are
watching Big House on the Prairie
but someone wife yells out red link want
to meet you we've been you know we watch
the show got the mug and whole schmear
you know oh you had them on yeah if I
think my son got it for Christmas of a
year or two ago so but I wasn't really
familiar with the other channels like
the 20 other channels that you guys have
just the main one yeah and so she had a
link to the the playing battleship one
and we're watching it and all they write
they like the voice and and the more it
went on you guys are like kind of
freaking out we want to meet you we're
just dying are you kidding me and we're
talking we're posting and sharing it
online well then there will say sorry to
interrupt but we assumed that you were
from Ohio I mean I it's one of the
things that we said yeah you you said I
assume he's been walking around in
America somewhere somewhere in the
Midwest and then somehow we probably
landed on a pile yeah so I mean I don't
know if we should apologize because
you're not from Ohio no I I don't know
that I've ever been to Ohio I'm sure
it's a lovely place totally missed
oh you're nailing that Ohio accent what
we meant by that is that you have a
voice that doesn't have any discernible
accent like you have like the American
relaxed it speaks to everyone I hope so
advertisers are you you're watching it
so this friend messaged it and sent a
link to my wife Facebook Messenger or
whatever it was and so we're watching it
and so after that we like share it hey
rhett and Link like you know enjoy it
and and then we didn't realize until a
little while later we looked at when it
was posted it's like oh this was from
August of once this is so last year
they're done this is not good this is
nothing is gonna have a gone Rihanna
never
yeah but just in case I'll send out a
tweet I did a little video sent out
tweet and I'll message them on Facebook
and I'll email their their producers or
whatever I need to do and and then the
mythical beasts on Twitter kind of took
over oh we found him and wrote link you
have to have him on he saw your tweet
yeah and it cuz I went to you and family
they see everything that goes to you
right and so they got excited about it
and then we were actually down here at
Disneyland and I kind of said hey we're
you know we're in the area if you want
to connect then I think finally Rhett
sent a tweet that said something along
the lines of glad somebody finally
showed this to you I was like wow it's
awesome he tweeted but that's that's as
far as it's gonna go that's that's the
end of yeah well let me tell you what I
was thinking at the time hmm we're gonna
meet Dave but I don't want to make I
don't want to make promises on you know
public media social media is smart so
but then we immediately began to yeah
well okay we gotta get in touch with
Dave we got it because what we talked
about on the show was bringing you into
to have an idol to town right night on
the town turned into an ear biscuit but
we wanted you to know the different
ideas we talked about where are you
gonna take us out after this for a night
on the town
yes absolutely yeah because what we do
is we would go now to meet and then we
would face away from each other feel
refreshed I don't remember that and Dave
because I got refreshed Dave would do
with vo what we were eating so we would
have to look at each other but we
wouldn't that well that's how he would
enjoy the meal that was one of the ideas
that we had I would tell you what he's
eating yeah and what you're eating him
okay well let's do that we should we
should follow through so that the
internet will continue to have faith in
us it's a two-way street
well then and then Rhett said I want him
to come and talk to my my children so
maybe they'd respect me talk to him and
say thanks yeah and then you said
something like I want you to come with
me to two parties and big me up I think
was your the phrase that you use big me
up well so here's what I've done Oh
since we're not going on a night on the
town together it will maybe after this
but I
this is not a prototype it's not my own
app but I thought I could maybe develop
something for you guys for these
instances oh yeah okay so with your kids
if you if you you run into a thing you
just you're worn out to long day here at
the studio's you don't really want to
respond you you've got these apps here
kids this is your dad he will blow you
up if you do not obey Him because of the
battleship obedience is disobedience
yeah I've been using that a lot lately
actually obey right away all the way and
with a glad heart that's right so you
should stay in our house this is we gave
up bodily noises are not considered a
joyful noise at church if you wanna be a
little more encouraging you know there's
I love you and even if you're just tired
just how about you get dad a sandwich oh
yeah you know he likes sandwiches so now
for the big up all right
you gonna bake me up yeah so you're at a
party yeah you need a little help
hello friends of link you may not know
that he scored two goals in one soccer
game with his left foot off foot now
friends of link you may not know that
link can perform around the world and
rocking the baby on a yo-yo you do right
well is that friends of link the honor
of getting a Linkous sandwich no just us
just you and I give everybody I get but
I get off types of friends you only get
sandwiches from your kids now because I
know you guys are very busy traveling
the world you got 20 channels going here
maybe romance at home is a little tough
sometimes you don't have the time to put
in that you'd like
so sometimes maybe the touch of a button
would be helpful but I don't want to ask
and of course final one wladim if you
find yourself in a situation where
because you got a lot of fans some might
get a little out of hand in case you
ever find yourself maybe kidnapped in a
difficult situation
yeah it could happen you can just this
is your your panic button okay I don't
know who you are I don't know what you
want if you are looking for ransom I can
tell you I don't have money but what I
do have are over 12 million subscribers
subscribers I've acquired over a very
long career basically beasts that make
me a nightmare for people like you if
you let me go now that'll be the end of
it I will not tweet to them
and they will not look for you they will
not pursue you but if you don't I will
tweet them they will look for you they
will find you and they will kill you
sandwich
man so so you're said if I can just get
this app to you you turn to kidnap
situation into me getting a salad that's
right really yeah yeah holy Rihanna I
played that for my wife and she thought
isn't that the guy from Princess Bride
the inigo montoya guy no I got to work
on my Liam Neeson girl that's good you
know your spouse keeps you honest she
does but that is good Liam I mean you
know I thought we were gonna have a
night out on the town but this is this
is better than anything we could have
ever expected oh we got weekend we can
take Dave with us in our pockets Dave
yes I am just astounded now I mean the
faith that I had in the Internet I'm
transferring all of it to you oh no
don't you man no okay how do you know
that you how do you discover that you
can you can do this kind of thing
mid-teens I discovered that it was not a
very good breakdancer and so I got more
breakdancing I tried I had like one good
move for about a week and then I lost it
though so I got more into the DJing
thing the scratching and mixing back in
the 80s oh you were scratching it makes
scratchin and mixin that translated into
radio in the mid teens which was not
something I thought I would do is just
okay let's let's do this and see when I
was a kid I wanted to be a DJ and I
tried to scratch mm-hmm
but I just messed up a lot of my mom's
records yeah because I didn't have the
proper equipment I had no clue what was
going on but you had two turntables and
you or you actually figured it out
yep working in you know under-21 dance
clubs at the time and
and and yeah it's learning things as I
went back then you know had the VCR
ready in case anything came on I wanted
to see you ready to tape something and
you know check it out and see how they
do it but but yeah so from that into
radio and then really just maybe 10
years ago I was introduced to the
broader world of voice over a friend
came into the studio and there were a
few of these casting site it's kind of
like acting I guess where you somebody
post a job or something they want and
you can audition for it either they like
it or they don't and you can get hired
for it and slowly started doing more of
that and got out a radio and stopped
doing it you were using the radio
equipment after hours to get I had
passion I had permission to use the
radio equipment from the radio station
and I was also producing a show at home
for my church they'd have like a daily
show that they Emma and the intro and
outro that I was producing that so I had
some equipment at home and they were
cool with me using at home so I had like
a couple of sound boards propped up with
like sneakers in the corner and from
that moved to the bedroom closet and
finally had a studio built on the Jean a
DJ you can kind of get once you have
these on and you hear you sell your
dreams so it it starts to morph over
time because you're getting that
immediate feedback right which I can see
how that goes directly into voiceover
but then voice-over is a different level
because you're not just using that DJ
voice that you've got right then you're
starting to tweak it for different
things and you ultimately are getting a
lot of sandwiches is liam neeson right
but I can see how that that happens over
years I guess it does I was really
nervous to even venture out into it it
was a kind of a step of faith because
there was some investment involved a
little bit early on and and my wife and
I were to say what do you think should
we do should I try it and so made the
the small investment just thought I'm
probably never gonna get this money back
because in small town radio which I was
in you know to do a commercial
you know if you got paid to do it all it
was it was minimal 30 bucks you know
whatever it was and so to try and see
you know getting any money back for this
I got hired pretty pretty quickly for a
job and when they told me how much
they'd they pay I was trying to play
cool like oh yeah that'll be in fine but
it was like this is gonna work any so I
just went to that like a national ad or
no that was I'm trying to remember
whereas before it wasn't national maybe
like a regional or maybe somewhere else
but I thought okay this this could
probably happened and we kind of took it
step by step
it just kind of kind of grew from there
to where I was finally able to maybe go
like halftime at the radio station then
finally it's like okay let's let's just
keep going and it's it's been great I
think I had a false sense of security
that I was afraid to step out because
the radio job felt like a job you know
it's like a regular job stable clocking
out but then I realize there's really no
such thing as a stable secure job right
you can do anything and it could end a
day so might as well do this and I have
to get up at 4:00 a.m. to do a morning
task Briana I've heard from multiple
people that vo is like it is the best
job at Hollywood it's great because well
you don't even have to be in Hollywood
if you don't want to be right you can't
because you're in up in the northwest in
Oregon right and you work out of your
house that's a pro move right there
I mean you turns away from the mighty
breeze hey zonday tayzonday started it I
don't have a cough switch here so so you
got we gotta get a cough but is it is it
as great as everybody's Dave Coulier
says it is I don't he's Dave Coulier has
the benefit of comparison because I
haven't done anything else in Hollywood
or you know TV write this as close as it
gets I guess for me you were not in in
in yet episode of full house no not to
my knowledge and so but it's a wonderful
community of people there are some
things that you still kind of have to
live down here for like a lot of
animation and stuff they kind of want
you here doing cuz they want you to come
in with like a director or writer in
person but there's a lot of stuff where
I can live there and and because of the
miracle that is the internet I can do
stuff from my garage and it goes all
over the world and do you think do you
think we've got it we got what it takes
because well you got the equipment for
sure lively
is I don't think I've got it you can be
on hold on but I got like it's not about
the depth of the voices no in fact
you're talking about having a piercing
thing it's like there sometimes is god
nobody no but like a monster-truck
commercial when there's a lot of like
the guitar playing you want somebody who
can pierce through it like a car
commercial hey the monster trucks are
coming to town your ticket now if a dirt
morita-ya jordan arena the misconception
is because you guys are by the way yeah
I'd be careful I didn't do that right um
that's you know being a DJ previously
it's an advantage but it's actually kind
of a disadvantage because nowadays they
don't really want you to sound most of
the auditions I receive no announcer
types don't want anybody who sounds like
an announcer they want somebody who
sounds like they're just from Ohio yes
just neutral normal guy just a lot of
times they'll describe but just like
you're sitting next to a guy at a
restaurant just talking to your best
friend that's what they want a lot of
course then they always choose the
announcer anyway but but that's what
they they want more of a natural things
so if you were just being yourself I
think there's another misconception that
you always have to have some kind of big
you know monster voice when you know and
I think they they want normal sounding
people and a variety of different things
often are you because just your normal
talking voice is like I kind of feel
like I'm listening to like a commercial
for like coffee or something it's like
it's it's there are minutes like you
know right like the cream on top of a
car yeah how would you talk about the
cream that you put in your coffee I
don't drink coffee so that's a downside
but that's your I have to that's the
acting but what about froth if you don't
like coffee you can suck off some Frost
I can't see a problem Rob maybe my eyes
met I'm really trying to be careful what
I say what person I don't know what that
means what percentage are just basically
your voice may be a little bit altered
because the Battleship voice is like
okay that's a character right right a
lot of times I just want this I put
together like a demo where they can hear
something like this but then there's
something excuse me
more of a I've got like a jewelry spot
on there where it is a lot more you know
there it's supposed to be sweet and you
know this this is the one that you want
to present to your loved one and you
kind of just toned down a little bit but
then there are some like the battleship
guy where it's a little more gritty and
sometimes they want more of a movie
trailer yeah yeah or Sam Elliott
sometimes sir I mean there's a variety
and so I've come to when I first started
that I auditioned for everything you
know and didn't land all of it but you
kind of you kind of narrow down to to
what your wheelhouse is and I was trying
out for a tween sounding if some kind of
kung fu animation or something was
trying out for this tween and they were
like can you sound a little younger can
you and my voice had evolved a bit and
and so I sent it to a friend who I
respect a guy a coach and a another
voiceover guy and he said yeah it
definitely sounds like a kid with a
mortgage what's the weirdest voiceover
you've ever done you guys have heard of
axe cop yes oh yeah yeah Ethan Nicole
who's the the artist and he was a
brother malachite was five at the time
and they came up with this yeah when
that started taking a viral as a comic
for him he wanted to do motion comics
and stuff like that and so just to
explain what he did was he would
interview his guys yeah whose interview
him like and he would his five-year-old
brother would tell the story right
written by a kid before written by kid
was a thing and then Jimmy Fallon does
like a written by a kid scripts like my
kids but this is later than one of the
first ones that was yeah and they would
mostly just kind of play actually I mean
it was his younger brother just in one
day saying let's go play axe cop and
you're like okay and what's they and
they just took off with it and he he
just start he's a phenomenal artist and
so he just started drawing it and when I
took off cuz it's just the kid's mind
was just limitless you know what they
could do I remember this axe cop season
one episode
one yeah let me pull this up here and so
I was doing the motion comics for it
online I think it was a rug burn
rug burn channel on YouTube yeah this is
four years ago yeah one day at the scene
of a fire but that's another one's a
perfect fireman a nurse actually acts
that way he became that's another great
voice guy named Bob sowed warrant I need
a partner now
so axe cop had tryouts and hired a
partner
my name is flute cap did you just do the
voice for flute [ __ ] no that was a guy
named Lee Gordon who did that who was
that guy
so I said yeah I'll do it but I want to
be axe cop and he let me round up some
of the other voice guys in there and
then that took off for him really well
it's a nick offerman got a hold of it
and they did some stuff on and ADHD I
think it was on Fox 5 a couple seasons
and then also Nick did it for the Fox
thing yeah and he did great
I was I was a little bitter at the time
I know that stuff kind of happens and
sees Nick Offerman I mean these if
anybody would probably actually be axe
cop and probably be Nick Offerman
attached some celebrity to it I mean you
set the template you know Nick Offerman
set around and and listen to the USI axe
cop I don't think he did he had his own
groove there cuz he sounds like Nick
Offerman but they did some great things
with night we were just just watching
him in fact axe cop related I did bring
you guys something because I heard that
you were fans as if you haven't already
given us enough by a being here and be
all of those voice tracks this is a good
on this not being here as a gift for me
this is great so I heard you guys had
been or our axe cop fans yes yeah it's
super cool it's so funny I mean how you
can see the five year old miss come
through in the concepts right I need a
partner you know it's like it's just
very but I have Ethan draw up a little
something for you guys
t-rex that's what stir yeah there's the
the t-rex
yeah whose front arms are Gatling guns
or whatever we call about holding that
in the right place
I'm holding in front of Battleship meg
is that good you getting a good shot of
that isn't that amazing she wasn't happy
to do that she's upset because she's not
in it but you're about to fall off the
back there and I'm winking I think he
lost an eye you were doing that refresh
voice and that's what he got this is our
night on the town with axe cop there's
two I mean it's the same one yeah but
true it twice exactly the same no I
printed it out ELISA how it works dad we
got to talk our wives that are putting
this up in the bed I don't know if
that's gonna work or not that's cool you
know I'll put it in my desk look thanks
for that anything yeah he's a great guy
have you ever done any ads for like
mashed potatoes one of the first things
we did was we talked to a woman who was
the voice of mashed potatoes for what
was that our Matt was a channel Alison
Fishman yeah Swedish meatballs man well
she I think yeah and mashed potatoes
potatoes it was a it was a food channel
on YouTube and we were just talking
about it the way she talked about food
made me so hungry
so we met her in person in New York yes
it wasn't nearly as thrilling as this
has been so far I'm buying your
affection so maybe that helps have you
done any Swedish meatballs I have not
done Swedish meatballs but I am potato
and I'm the voice for simply potatoes
Pollock right now which you probably
heard on the Food Network perhaps or
other places no but it kind of appetite
on my site Dave Deandra calm I think the
video is rather on there but they wanted
me to channel a bit of a Donald
Sutherland just how he talks really you
know kind of quietly about orange juice
or whatever he was talking some simply
something that he was doing how did you
maybe you maybe I must have you looked
at me and thought nope I'm serious axe
cop and potato it's
warm and it's warm in its starchy here
we go yeah you gotta put our business
card in starchy and frothy and front you
got a frothy voice alright some call it
a spud or a tater and simply potatoes we
call it our calling to bring you fresh
never frozen potatoes grown close to us
where they're simply peeled and prepped
real potato goodness that goes from farm
to fridge to that oh so delicious moment
on your fork again simply made simply
satisfying simply potatoes yeah but what
are they you see the packaging there
it's I think they have a variety of
products in your freezer section simply
potato what else is it though they just
simply points but what is in there I
didn't look at the ingredients but I
think it's just simply potatoes
you looked at the script you could get
me to eat poison but if you talked about
it in that way try you could do a
commercial for arsenic gonna be like Oh
warm and starchy give us a little
arsenic it's very sweet going down but
it's got a bit of an aftertaste then you
die see but I don't care you gotta hit
the front hit the product to the website
I've already eaten it before I died how
do I order it have you ordered like
arsenic arsenic dotnet look at our thing
the last thing you'll ever eat right
spots - the last thing you'll ever eat
last thing you'll ever eat arsenic yeah
so arsenic folks you can call me I might
look at my website look look at our comm
see if that's the thing what am i
searching for arsenic calm why am i
searching for it I'm just gonna go to it
I'm gonna type it up here and go to it
Arsenic and Old Lace
what is that resources curio supplies
and fine gifts hold on we can get it
personal
whoa we're in we're in in a cult okay
you got to get out of here back out
quickly back away incorrect let's go
back to Dave's McKay's website say a
family friendly please
okay oh you do a Morgan Freeman I see I
do get hired everyone someone to do it
I'm Morgan Freeman we could have used
you recently we had an idea okay so yeah
it's a future reference you may have
seen we did you may have seen the
tonight she got all this tonight show
yeah yeah my daughter said in fact I
think they're gonna be on The Tonight
Show just before they're with you but
then there was a rerun last night or
something so guess you guys were not
yeah it was it was almost a month ago
now right yeah it was weeks ago
yeah mini so we did we'll it's more with
Gingka right and one of the ideas that
we were talking about that we didn't end
up doing and I think I know why we
didn't do it because Morgan Freeman
ended up being on the show the next
night mm-hmm
but we had an idea to do one of the
s'mores was just gonna be a regular
s'more mm-hmm but it was going to be
voiced over by Morgan Freeman as we ate
it and we were gonna call it's Morgan
Freeman great right yeah they liked the
idea but then they ultimately said they
couldn't do it and we even put it like
well you don't have to get Morgan
Freeman we just get a voiceover gotta do
it we didn't we hadn't talked yet we
didn't know we ended with you six months
ago like I was supposed to all right we
did all the time I should have been on
our luggage but can we can we can we
make that moment happen now sure I mean
we don't have any s'mores but you know
what's a s'more yeah you can kind of see
why we're so obsessed with voiceover
because it fit because you always need
it it it we just feel like it would
enrich every moment of our lives and
you've done nothing but prove that but
yet we keep pushing no it's I mean we've
just beaten arsenic man and now we're
eating s'mores oddly no the arsenic
would be similar to the s'more voice
better ingredients this is not an ad
this is like like Happy Feet narration
this is just like a play-by-play hate
him to Happy Feet it was March of the
same movie penguins penguins he played
one of the Penguins okay I'm wrong Wow
look at that took a left as you Kris
graham cracker lightly toasted
marshmallow and a big old hunk of
chocolate we don't need this show just
to do biscuits
Morgan Freeman calm dr. Bosman let me
eat mine you can say the exact same
thing oh right
it looks like links got a little too
close to the fire but some people like
it that way
taking a he looks a little distraught
now he's happy but that was no
marshmallow that was penguin you just go
right in that's one that I have gotten
more comfortable with it was it was one
where I was auditioning for it and never
getting in fact this uh buddy of mine
Paul Hernandez and I would go back worth
trying to do that and audition for it
never get it and then never getting
Morgan Freeman ever giving not a like
specific right correct
and then it just I grew a little more
confident in fact I was at a voiceover
workshop one weekend and the guy who was
coaching it was away naturally and so we
were kind of just goofing around reading
scripts but then some of the other voice
guys started kind of throwing out their
accents and and things that they do just
kind of like go
what do you got you know kind of thing
and I was like panicking like I want to
do this but I've never really done it in
front anybody before and I thought I
could just go do a normal New York thing
or something you know something stupid
in the knowledge right but while I'm
reading I'm hearing them just like my
confidence boosted up a little bit so
then I worked with a.m. actually worked
with a dialect coach for a while on that
one to just because there's some
subtleties in there because he's not
he's got a very unique voice obviously
yeah and so it's just it's getting honed
and a little better and it's just a fun
one to do and it doesn't hurt me at all
some of the you know like battleship I
do that for an hour and for the day but
right well for Morgan Freeman from a
legal standpoint I mean you're saying
that you there's people putting out
auditions for I want it to be like
Morgan Freeman but if you nail Morgan
Freeman's voice isn't there some sort of
legal ramifications that I'm sure there
is often times they'll say we wanted to
sound kind of like Morgan Freeman but
not exactly like Morgan Freeman I did
something for a selectquote senior I
think it wasn't it kind of had a Morgan
Freeman vibe to it but sometimes they do
but it's not really like a national
broadcast thing it may be for somebody's
website or tutorial or something like
that so but if I got big you might be in
trouble I mean I know I might I don't
know I just probably look into that no I
think you're in the clear but when they
called I just say it's all right
[Laughter]
first time idiot what are you talking
that's great but then you're talking
about preserving your voice through the
more painful so you could do some damage
with certain voices like when I was
trying to do that what monster truck
what actually so on a recent GMM oh when
I was doing a hell burger yeah when it
was the the the VR not VR that the
burger that was digital vloggers taking
taking the place of their were like how
could watch hell burger all day and then
there was somebody who like Sam and said
actually I'm a I'm studying voice or
something like that and that Bret's
voice is very unsustainable therefore
it's not a good voice he could never do
that professionally or something like
that somebody came in and said that what
does that mean really are you damaging
my voice as I was doing unsustainable I
think that there are and this is not
something that I've studied and
certainly no expert at but I know that
there are techniques and things where
you can do it to to where you can even
for singers some of the screamo singers
how they can just keep doing that night
after night they yeah there's some
technique and training that goes into
being able to do that I really don't
have that if I know I'm gonna be
screaming like if it's a for a video
game and all I'm doing is screaming and
dying pretty much I'll schedule that for
you know as late on like a Friday
afternoon for the session as I can to
give myself the weekend to recover so
I'm back to normal by Monday and doing
potatoes or whatever I'm I'm doing so
back to the taters so yeah there's I'm
sure and I'm sure if you google it's
there there are techniques and ways that
you can do a lot of screaming and
yelling but preserve it and do it in in
a way that it will not wear out yeah if
you're gonna do it because if well I
think if you're gonna be I think because
in the context of what people were
saying it was like oh I would love to
see a hell burger show or whatever it's
like well he couldn't do that because
it's a voice that you if you're gonna do
a character voice you've got to be able
to do it over and over again mm-hmm do
you have battleship at your house I do
after that friend called and said I
think this is you on this game and I was
like right yeah then we immediately went
out and got it and had a kick out of
playing do you like it better than just
the regular old we don't even have the
old battleship anymore so yeah it's it's
it's fun and the kids get used to
hearing me doing stuff you know after a
while they you know upgrade adds simply
potatoes wonderful you know and they've
heard it because I was in radio and
stuff so they've been used to hearing me
but the coolest thing that ever happened
was the night that found out you guys
the fact that you guys were geeking out
about my voice
they're my achievement unlocked as a dad
I suddenly became very cool as a dad
way more than doing some national
commercial later slot link like dad get
as much mileage out of it is you know it
cuz battleship itself and gets old
pretty quick yeah even when every on it
yeah even with Rihanna and your amazing
voice it's like alright I kind of get it
hmm you know you sunk my you sunk my
destroyer in my my what's that other
carrier aircraft carrier yeah all the
carriers what's kind of in think I don't
know who the other guy is on there's a
couple other voice guys on there to lose
it
no I thought they were the one guy
almost camp and he had like a muppet
kind of thing going on is really awesome
I really I don't know how they were but
that's a compliment hey what no it's
cool I really like the one of the you
know free player when they do stuff is
I'm disappointed to hear that you don't
have like a battleship guy voice reunion
everywhere we pictured you all in the
same room with that well you know just
playing the game I was in my interview
in my garage and organize a lurtz
like right in the Navy who can make that
happen the name if you were one of the
other voice guys on battleship oh yeah
next time you work in that internet
faith I like that well dude thanks for
you know selling arsenic to us if you
had it we would all be dead would be
we're gonna enjoy some simply potatoes
later and my wife is gonna be hearing
your voice tonight
weird yeah my pleasure thanks guys yeah
thank you and there it is our voiceover
conversation with a voice of our art
well we didn't I guess we didn't do a
voice over well technically this whole
voice over there it was well no no
because I mean technically a voice over
is when you voice over something we're
just kind of voicing the thing that's
happening that we weren't over anything
yeah I mean we're over the thing that's
happening so I'm not over it I don't
think I'll ever be yeah that was that
was his life change he was moving it
just reminded me how good of an idea it
was to get him involved in our lives
yeah and and I you know it hit me when
we were talking about the voice of
mashed potatoes and now we've met two
voices of mashed potatoes Alison Alison
Fishman I think now it's it's got to be
our life mission to seek out all potato
related voiceover artists and make a
personal connection with does that
include anybody that does like a
commercial for french fries for like
fast food yeah that's really why no no
no no it's gonna be a commercial for
potatoes potatoes that in one form or
mashed like because his his had mashed
in it which was crazy at first I thought
it was just simply potatoes but it turns
out that you can just you can mash them
you can well you can get a mashed
version you can simply mash potatoes but
what are they they're just simply potato
exactly all right that you know I mean
it's like why not just buy potatoes what
is the slogan that is that's kind of the
question but what are they simply
potatoes then why not just buy potatoes
I think he's my follow-up question
because of the voice over that's the
power of voice over they the voice over
talked us into just buying sack sacks of
potatoes instead of just buying bags of
intact potato do you want to know the
real reason I mean the real reason is
because it's my told you the real reason
well it's easier than potatoes so good
potatoes have to be peeled and boiled
these have been cooked probably already
I don't know I don't really know so
they're not simply potato I didn't
really pay
much attention to the advertisement I
was just thinking I was just thinking
about his frothy voice man I don't mind
the froth back oh yeah and it was a good
experience well wouldn't you say yes
well let us know hashtag your biscuits
yeah you can do that in the comments on
this video if you're watching on that
this is mythical YouTube channel which
is where you can enjoy the audio and
video version the voiceover and the
video part that has been voiced over
under the video under in the voice so if
you just want to enjoy the voice-over
part that can be made available to you
and it has been made available to you
everywhere podcasts aren't available to
you including five iTunes leave a review
on iTunes SoundCloud it up however you
podcast I trust you're listening to it
that way right now yes or you can switch
at any point we'll make it available in
all those ways we appreciate your ears
and your eyes and hearts and those
biscuits you may own your potatoes
[Music]